a perfect system is patient focused it's
not built around the caregivers it's not
built around building opportunities it's
not built around revenue streams it's
built around the patient so the perfect
system focus is on the patient and the
perfect system has all of the
information about each patient so that
knowledgeable caregiver is working with
the patient can figure out what the
optimal care pattern for that patient is
and if you're a healthy person in
pre-diabetic the right plan for you is
to avoid diabetes if you have diabetes
and you get comorbidities the right plan
for you is a plan that links your
caregivers and manages the complications
and everybody has a different perfect
outcome but everybody should have a care
plan everyone should have somebody
working with them a care team support
team working with them to optimize the
care outcomes perfect system can do that
in the imperfect system patient's
stumble into the emergency room that's
unconnected to anything else they do
they they get care for their asthma in
one place you get care for their kidney
failure in another place completely
unrelated care imperfect system is built
around the individual provider business
sites and not around care perfect system
has a data flow as information going to
the patient's has patients able to make
informed choices so when you've got one
hospital that has a death rate for heart
disease at three or four times the next
hospital over patients should know that
there should be an informed set of
choices for patients are huge
differences in ecology outcomes if you
have stage 3 cancer your likelihood of
living six months is significantly
different depending on the oncologist
you choose nobody knows that if you have
a mammogram read the accuracy of the
mammogram very significantly based on
the reader some readers have twice as
many member grams getting to stage three
and death as other readers and nobody
knows that people don't know that so
people assume I have a mammogram and
protect it so the perfect system would
keep track of mammogram success rates
cancer survival rates bone surgery
success rates if you just tore through
the process heart surgery success rates
and make that information part of the
data flow the patients can use so you
need the right data you need the right
incentives you need patient-focused care
plans and you put all that together
combine it with current medical science
and there's a great opportunity to do
some really wonderful things for people
what we have instead is a silent system
now we at Kaiser Permanente because
we're vertically integrated and do a lot
of this work now and we are doing it the
rest of the world isn't vertically
integrated so it's harder to do a lot of
those pieces but what the rest of the
world can do is virtual integration if
you can't be vertically integrated you
can still create integration links using
the computer care registries data flows
and create care plans for patients and
then provide feedback to that from other
sources like the claims processing
system if you go to the doctor and you
have a claim filed on your behalf by the
doctor there's the diagnosis there's the
treatment there's the cost of care
there's the person who did at the time
frames most of the information that's
it's in a medical record is in the claim
it's not timely accuracy levels a little
lower its not real time but it's there
and so if you're having asthma attacks
multiple asthma attacks that will show
up on both the electronic medical record
and the claims database and right now
the electronic medical record can use it
to make an improvement I care the claims
database is wasted that data is not
being used and it could be used and
should be used so part of the American
health care reform agenda should be to
create access to that database and
require everybody who pays for care in
America to use that database and focus
on issues like asthma care to make sure
that every asthmatic
basically ends up with at least a
computer tracking their care and some
kind of a care plan that will improve
the asthma care
it makes huge sense to have
as much alignment as you can possibly
get between the revenue stream and the
care delivery and and so we we need to
reward the best providers for being the
best providers some some processes are
very individual like knee surgery
typically involves a knee surgeon and
the patient and doesn't involve quite a
few other areas although there are
therapists involved in the recovery
other conditions like diabetes take an
entire team of caregivers and so you
need a team coordination a team data
flow a team reward system and the very
best payers ought to reward and partner
with teams of caregivers for the chronic
conditions and then create a marketplace
that rewards the best performance by the
individual performers and if you did
both of those things you would have
better knee surgery and better diabetic
care and if you if the insurance company
stands back from the whole process and
isn't part of it relative to the benefit
package or data flow information flow
channel and patients to the best
providers I think that does the patience
of the service because that the teamwork
should be there in that partnership
should be there so the ideal model going
forward is a linked model and also there
are quite a few vertically integrated
care systems in America that ought to be
thinking about stepping up to the plate
and taking prepayment much like Kaiser
and I think as we go forward depending
on health health care reform shakes out
that could happen
but I think there's an understanding
actually on the part of President Obama
some of the key Senate leaders some of
the key House leaders that the care
delivery system is not organized
optimally right now in that we ought to
be working toward a better model and I
think there's an appreciation of team
care I think there's an appreciation of
data flows datasets data tracking
informed patient choice I mean I think
all of that is is in the air but it's
not sufficiently in the bills and so
we've had discussions conversations
hearings about those kinds of issues and
then when the bills finally got written
some of those pieces didn't get
incorporated the one even when Senator
Baucus did his hearing the other day
verse press conference and he talked
about how he would like to see
healthcare organized in the future one
of the things he cited was US mail
Cleveland Clinic guising or some of the
other care systems and said it would be
good for America to reorganize and to
move down those pants I think though
that the way America can get there is
not by trying to reorganize the system
from from that perspective it's by
saying we need to fix a couple things in
this country we need to have half as
many kids with asthma attacks we need to
figure out how we put all the pieces in
place to get there and if we set a goal
like that diagnosis every kid make sure
that every kid has a treatment plan make
sure there's a database make sure you're
tracking what happens to every kid when
you put all those pieces in place they
lend themselves to a system and because
you can't achieve those things unless
you have tools data information somebody
accountable so if we set a few goals for
the country and then work backward from
the goals to the plan I think and take
it very seriously and they have reward
systems based on achieving those plans I
think what will happen then was well
there would be a natural gravitation of
caregivers into more tightly organizing
nated care teams but that's not going to
happen until there is a reason to do it
the caregiver is not going to reorganize
just for the theory of the door because
somebody give a nice speech and it
sounded good or because Mayo is a great
brand or we have a great read that
they're going to do it there because
doing it makes it more likely that they
will cut the number congestive heart
failure or tax in half and if they do
that if they band together to do that
and they're rewarded for doing that that
model will work so I think we've got to
get their goal first rewards tools and
then I think there would be an
aggregation that will come out of it but
it will be an aggregation that results
from the goal not one that creates the
outcome you know if you look at any
other business if you look at any to go
to a factory there are no factories in
the world that will build a tool and
throw the tool randomly into the factory
and hope that somebody picks it up and
it uses it some smart way every factory
says this is the product we want we want
to produce the hubcap I want the sub cap
to have a ninety-nine point nine percent
lack of variability okay to do that what
are the tools have to be and then they
work backward from the hubcap to the
tool kit health care is the only thing
that throws a new wrench in and says I
hope somebody in there uses it and
somehow in the end hubcaps better
doesn't work so we have to start we have
to start with a hubcap we have to start
with the outcome we have to cut the
number of congestive heart failure
patient so the number of asthma tags and
then build the tool kit from that and
then the benefit package the Blue Cross
pays has to reward those outcomes
because if they ignore the outcomes or
do as we do now and actually reward
perverse outcomes care delivery will not
change
this country responds very quickly to
incentives so if you created a care
environment where the care teams who cut
the number of asthma eczema when get
more money get more patients benefit if
you created a situation where the care
teams that have half as many kidney
failures with everybody will gravitate
to that model health care providers are
very very smart you don't get through
medical school or hospital
administration school without being very
smart so everybody very carefully
studies the compensation system and
understands exactly what's rewarded and
what's not and if you try to force
people into Tina just for the sake of
putting in the teams and there's no
reward involved and there's no positive
outcome people won't go to teens but if
you create a reward system that rewards
the result of teams then people will
figure 15 very creative ways to form the
teens and so it has to be on the results
you've got to build the architecture as
every other market does on the product
that's sold I think about cell phone so
the cell phone market is based on the
product that's sold you could not sell a
cell phone today of the kind that we
used 34 years ago in the market because
that's not what people want to buy today
and so the cell phone market is
constantly changing constantly improving
because they're rewarded by the change
they don't they're not changing because
they like to change their changing
because they're trying to get to that
next market share because there's a win
for them by coming up with a better
phone they engineer the better phone
there is no win and healthcare right now
for coming up with a better outcome
there is no there's actually a loss and
so you've got to change that that has to
change and healthcare people are just as
smart as cell phone engineers so if you
change that then the entire system will
follow that and that's where the change
has to happen and it's got to be in
rewarding a different set of outcomes
and then
people will organize differently put
toolkits in place to get to those
outfits